today
is on the line in fayetteville north
carolina hi you day how are you
hey how you doing today thanks for
taking my call sure man what's up
yeah so i put myself in a bad financial
spot
um i ended up going to a buy here pay
here place
and buying a car on like august 3rd of
this month the agreement was to put down
a thousand dollars and then the next
time i get paid
put down another 500 and that will
complete my down payment
um basically i told the salesman i don't
get paid until the end of the month
so i wouldn't have been able to make the
payment until i get paid
um last week they came and repo the car
so two weeks after you bought it
yes two weeks after i bought it did you
give them the thousand up front
yes i gave them a thousand up front good
lord wow that sounds super aggressive
well it is it's a tote to know it's a
scam lot hey uh you
you day what was the interest rate on
that loan do you remember yeah 22
yeah gracious this was never intended to
be a blessing in your life
no only theirs well
yeah so i don't know what to do they
said i can pay
the 500 nope plus three hundred dollars
to get the vehicle back
no they got all they're gonna get out of
you ready nope
okay you got out you got out of a bear
trap for a thousand bucks
good luck i mean you got mo you got
mostly one of your legs intact
yeah so you you run with the other leg
man you get away these people are did
you not figure out you got scammed
well i just needed another card to get
back
did you answer my question did you not
figure out you got scammed
22 freaking percent and you paid 1500
down or you would have and that's all
the stinking car was worth to start with
probably
yeah no don't delay hey no listen
did you hear 22 percent let it go
it's frozen frozen let it go run
okay so you get paid 500 bucks right
you got you got some you got 500 bucks
in your and 300 that you could see in
your future
that you were thinking about giving to
these scam artists right
yeah okay so let me let's walk through
what you do now instead of doing that
because the first thing you have to do
is realize you got screwed
and you don't go back to a place where
you got screwed okay
is that fair okay now the second thing
is
can you scrape together the 800 you were
talking about giving to them a few
minutes ago
yeah i actually get paid this friday so
how much do you get paid on friday
uh it should be twenty five hundred
dollars good and how are you getting
back and forth to work right now
i actually have a truck another vehicle
that i use as a business truck
slash uh work truck but you're able to
use it on a personal level
uh yes uh it's it's currently mine and i
have a car note on that as well
and it needs repairs so i had gotta i
was going to get another car
just so i could put it in the shop for
it to get repaired
what what is the nature of the repairs
it needs hon
um it needs about uh two thousand
dollars worth of repairs it's engine
repairs
okay and how old are you i'm 27.
and what do you think this truck is
worth without repairing it
um about four thousand dollars and i'm
upside down on my loan
right now how much do you owe the on the
loan 8400
okay you've been doing poorly with cars
haven't you yeah he's got car out of
state
yeah okay so um
[Music]
and it needs two thousand dollars in
repairs
and then it would be worth what six
thousand or seven thousand
yes okay still oh and eighty four
hundred
all right but it but it'll drive a
little bit
yeah what are the nature of the repairs
it needs
um basically they said that i needed um
the gasket fixed inside the engine and
then
um basically i needed new shocks
and a couple other things and it came
out to two thousand dollars
gotcha okay well you've blown a head
gasket you can go without shocks a
really long time in a truck
um doing a head job on what kind of
truck is this
a brand uh it's a gmt sierra
okay pickup truck all right i want you
did you did the dealer give you this
price
i gave you the repair who gave you the
repair estimate
i went to three different places and uh
one was 1800
another was 2 000 and then another one
was 2400.
were they all dealers or were any of
these mechanics individual mechanics
these
these were individuals okay good good
yeah all right
well i'm gonna break out the shocks away
from the head head gasket okay
the head gasket's probably the bulk of
that but they may be
getting you for five or six hundred
bucks on the shocks here i don't know
all right and uh this truck's got some
miles doesn't it like a couple hundred
thousand
you know it actually only has a hundred
and sixty thousand on it 160 yeah
that's kind of like a couple hundred
okay yeah i mean it's it's got some wear
and tear
all right so let's think of a strategy
that says five years from today
three years from today two years from
today what are you in the best
shape of with the vehicle is it
uh buying a car on payments no we just
experienced that we do need to get the
truck repaired
at some point and yes we need to buy a
car
before we do that or have made other
arrangements for
transportation during the time i would
talk to one of the mechanics that's
thinking of doing the repair
and see if they have a car that they
will rent you for the two weeks that
your truck is down instead of
buying a second car
okay just get you some kind of a loaner
off their back lot that's a hooptie
even if you pay them a little bit for
the loaner that's better than
buying a car right now you don't need to
do that and then let's get the truck
repaired
and let's sell it and get out of the
debt
now we have no debt and no car but
you by then you could have put together
this is all going to take till christmas
but then you could have put together a
little bit of money and you pay cash for
a two or three thousand dollar car
let's get you out of the land of car
payments completely
but this truck probably needs to be
repaired to get the most value out of it
okay and i still um i still have about
three more years on my truck payment no
you don't not if you sell it
okay i didn't know i can sell a vehicle
without uh yeah
you fix it and sell it and you'll be
probably a thousand dollars in the hole
you write a check for that thousand
you're out of that completely
save back a thousand fifteen hundred
bucks and get you a little beater car
for cash and that's your first step away
from this entire mess
it is not financing something at the
tote and out lot at 22
interest you got screwed yeah yeah you
date you you're out of the car loan
business
is what we've just laid out for you okay
you don't you're not going to do that
but honestly reach out to that mechanic
find they've got a loaner car or
something you can pay a couple hundred
dollars a week
to be able to tell they've got to get to
that gum truck fix right let's sit
around there two months
they put the head gasket on it's a
one-week job max
okay and you know and then you can do
the shocks later or not do them and sell
the truck
160 000 mile truck that drives like it's
worn out is not a big problem when
you're selling it
blown head gasket is yeah
okay and this car that you're going to
save up and buy for cash this is going
to be a car you're going to have for a
year or two
because you're going to keep saving up
to be able to upgrade but no more
financing ooday raise your right hand
say i promise to never borrow on a car
again
i promise to never borrow on a car again
if you want to be wealthy if you don't
want to be financially stressed you know
how much stress you've had in the last
48 hours
a lot yeah if you never want to be there
again never have a car payment again
keep that promise to yourself you don't
have to keep it to me
but car payments eat your butt alive man
and they definitely been eating your
butt
wow on 22
well the scam on those guys is they they
fully intended to take his thousand
bucks is what they did
they set him up thousand dollars down
they went and got the truck going got
the car before he got paid to pay the
500 they knew
what was happening and it was probably a
1500
car a lot of times they sell the car for
the pro the value of the car
is the down payment and all the money
they make at 22 profit
and so that's a scam lot you just got it
and listen it says tote the note
that's for people who've lost their
freaking minds run
that's right it's the payday lender of
the car business it really is
sorry oday man i'm sorry you lost your
thousand bucks but that's all you're
gonna lose if you listen to us